with forces battling on the ground
ukraine is begging the u.s and its
allies for more firepower in the sky now
the biden administration is negotiating
with poland to give ukraine its old
soviet-made mig fighter jets and replace
them with made f-16s we're talking
with our polish friends right now
about what we might be able to do to
backfill
their needs if in fact they choose to
provide these fighter jets to to the
ukrainians lincoln visited moldova a
western leaning former soviet republic
pledging u.s aid as that small nation
bordering ukraine fears it could be
putin's next target
pressure is building across america and
in congress for the biden administration
to do more to destabilize russia this
weekend visa mastercard and paypal
stopped doing business in that country
the white house vows more sanctions
against russia are coming to dial up the
heat the ruble is worth less than a
penny right now
the russian central bank is is not
not functioning uh completely the stock
market has been closed a new poll shows
80 percent of americans are also calling
for the u.s to stop buying russian oil
despite gas prices at their highest
level in a decade
i
would rather support ukraine in whatever
we can if that means gas prices hike up
like i would
i would pay it but experts warn the
ripple effect of targeting russian crude
oil exports will be costly anything that
touches a truck commerce deliveries
groceries lumber going to the store
anything that is being shipped via semi
truck is eventually going to get hit
it's a price the majority of americans
say they are willing to pay to try and
help save ukraine
jennifer johnson global news washington